bonjour et bienvenue au théâtre national
de l'odéon à l'occasion de l'ouverture
de saison russe tout le long de l'année
2020 en france à paris mais aussi en
belgique et au luxembourg vont se
dérouler près de 420 événements
culturels dans 90 villes différentes
nous sommes allés voir travailler le
directeur de théâtre de l'odéon stéphane
roche règle c'est l'un des plus grands
metteurs en scène français
il s'est attaqué à l'oncle vania de
tchekhov le monument du théâtre russe
qui met en scène avec une troupe
moscovite
j'ai aussi rencontré vladimir fédorovski
l'ancien diplomate soviétique devenu
écrivain français et auteur de nombreux
best seller traduit dans le monde entier
il nous a raconté ses égéries russe vous
allez découvrir le destin extraordinaire
de ces femmes qui sont restés dans
l'ombre des grands hommes mais qui ont
marqué l'histoire comme olga khokhlova
les pousses de picasso ou encore elsa
triolet la muse de louer un bref une
émission comme d'habitude pleine de
surprises vous êtes prêts alors c'est
parti de lisbonne à vladivostok
[Musique]
on
stéphane bron speck n'a pas choisi la
pièce oncle vania par hasard
il n'en est pas à sa première pièce de
tchekhov il a déjà mis en scène en
france la cerise et les trois soeurs la
mouette
mais c'est la première fois qu'il
s'attaque à ce grand classique du
théâtre pour son adaptation
stéphane braunschweig a fait le choix
d'une mise en scène moderne qui colle
aux propos de cette fable aux accents
écolo qui il y à plus de 100 ans mettait
déjà en garde
l'homme face à la destruction de la
nature c'est une pièce très intéressante
pour pour nous aujourd'hui parce que
elle parle beaucoup de la question de la
destructivité de l'homme et aujourd'hui
quand on entend ça on pense bien sûr aux
incendies qu'il ya eu en amazonie en
sibérie est maintenant en australie des
incendies absolument terrible et on sait
que c'est tous ces incendies
la cause est tu m'aimes se sont pas des
catastrophes naturelles
ce sont les résultats de l'action de
l'homme sur la planète et je trouve que
c'est intéressant pour nous d'entendre
ce discours aujourd'hui parce que tout
d'un coup il a et n'est plus un discours
visionnaire il est un discours c'est un
discours réaliste je suis un artiste on
interprète j'essaie de faire entendre la
parole de tchekhov de mettre en scène
les situations les personnages mais
j'aime bien que une pièce classique
pièce qui a déjà toute une histoire
puisse raisonner avec le monde dans
lequel on vit
la pièce est jouée avec des acteurs
russes en version originale sous-titrée
en français
[Musique]
cette tragédie familiale
ce classique de la culture russe a
d'abord été monté un moscou joué au
théâtre et des nations en septembre
dernier avec cette troupe formée
spécialement pour cette occasion
[Musique]
de par son statut de metteurs en scène
étrangers
stéphane braunschweig à la volonté
d'innover dans une pièce déjà si souvent
adapté moi j'arrive avec une fraîcheur
en fait moi je leur dis vous savez on va
monter la pièce comme si on n'avait
jamais monté en fait je n'ai pas cette
culture russe je n'ai pas donc donc je
dirais que j'arrive avec un regard qui a
une certaine fraîcheur une certaine
virginité et ça permet de retrouver le
tchèque afin de me débarrasser de
couches de deux traditions en fait et je
pense qu'on a pu comme ça à aborder
tchekhov avec beaucoup d'honnêteté
beaucoup d'auto d'authenticité et bien
sûr je parle pas russe mais j'ai une
très bonne traductrice je connais je
connais le texte par coeur et je peux
très bien comprendre quand ils jouent
leurs intentions de jeu tout ça pour moi
ça me parvient ce sont des as et de très
bons acteurs ils sont très expressifs
ils sont claires quant aux bijoux
et parmi ces acteurs iggy numéro 9 qui a
le rôle principal un statut à part
[Musique]
s'il est sur scène aujourd'hui
il est également le directeur du théâtre
des nations de moscou où a donc été
monté la pièce une double casquette qui
ne l'a pas empêché de se fier à stéphane
braunschweig pour les diriger 4 mais
quel est ce un staff
il me semble que stéphane à créer
quelque chose d'unique pour ce spectacle
salucci là un style qui lui est propre
et qui colle absolument à du tchekhov un
langage universel
il n'y a donc pas besoin de traduction
parce qu'il me semble que tout ce qui se
passe sur scène et compris par tous et
ce n'est pas seulement l'amour us ou
ceux qui parlent russe qui peuvent
comprendre si mais tous ceux qui sont
assis dans la salle
la chine a dit stop à paillotes iliad a
généré groupe j'espère vraiment que cela
touchera les spectateurs guigne t'as
quoi j'ai switché tape je ne me souviens
pas avoir eu un rôle aussi difficile
malgré le fait que stéphane ou 10 dès le
départ qu'il n'avait pas spécialement de
concept et qui n'allait rien inventé ces
retouches mais qu'il allait plutôt nous
guider à chaque étape du texte cela me
faisait sentir dans l'impasse car nous
étions à l'affût de chaque décision
elles tiennent salon ni ne connaissent
pas ça elle nous les russes savons
comment jeu du tchekhov jeu mais nous a
dit que le plus important est le texte
tiers et le décryptage de ce qu'a voulu
dire l'auteur pourquoi je te prêter aux
casadesus
à l'image de stéphane braunschweig qui
tentent d'innover dans sa mise en scène
[Musique]
m
pas facile de livrer une nouvelle
interprétation un des rôles déjà tant
jouer et qui appartiennent au patrimoine
culture et russe comme me l'expliquait
et les avais tu as boyard sky à cannes
père prête le rôle de lna justin bieber
quand tu es choisi pour un rôle du
répertoire classique
tu veux toujours trouver quelque chose
qui était propre
quelque chose de particulier je pense
qu'en france ce n'est pas le cas mais en
russie il y a toujours au moins cinq
théâtres qui joue oncle vania peut-être
un peu moins et c'est pourquoi tu veux
trouver quelque chose qui t'appartient
mode et brett mon coach
les autres avant toi n'ont pas non plus
tout réinventer et c'est intéressant de
voir comment l'on va interpréter nos
personnages
comment stéphane va monter la pièce
quelle est sa vision et comment je
ressens mon personnage et les nappes
polluées au final pour moi ce qui en
ressort c'est de la sympathie et un
rapprochement avec mon personnage
sympathique ne risque
[Musique]
c'est le soir de la première oncle vania
est le premier spectacle d'une série qui
s'étendra durant toute l'année 2020 la
pièce inaugure les saisons russes
en france 400 événements auront lieu
dans plus de 50 villes
du théâtre donc mais aussi des
expositions ou encore les traditionnels
bals et russe un événement pour la
france et la russie dont les deux
ministres de la culture ont fait le
déplacement
c'est un formidable moyen de pouvoir à
la fois pour nos compatriotes de voir la
diversité et la richesse de la culture
russe et de la création artistique russe
et de conforter l'amitié entre nos deux
pays les biens entre les institutions
culturelles les musées les théâtres les
organismes de spectacles et de concerts
sont plutôt bons
et certains événements les renforce
pour ce qui constitue le paysage
politique cela semble avoir besoin
d'améliorations mais nous y travaillons
j'ai tout de même des relations avec les
ministères étrangers et avec les
fonctionnaires en charge de la culture
nous souhaitons des relations plus
ouverte et il me semble que les saisons
russes portent nécessairement y
contribuer parce qu'aux passionnés dans
l'âme russe et à la fin moi je pleurais
plat personnellement je crois que c'est
le plus beau moment de ma vie c'était
extraordinaire extraordinaire le jeu des
acteurs qu'il formidable le fait qu'il
parle en russe et je pense que c'est les
acteurs et les acteurs absolument
incroyable les actrices et les acteurs
sont vraiment remarquables et le
chanceux métaphysique de cette pièce
touche profondément on est ému et c'est
vraiment une belle image de la culture
ruches sont les français qui trop
souvent l'ignorent j'ai maintenant
rendez vous avec me crie 20 bladimir
fait de rock ce qui est d'ordinaire
connu pour ses ouvrages plus de 40
traduit dans le monde entier
mais c'est pour autre chose que je le
rencontre aujourd'hui pour un spectacle
musical
[Musique]
l'ancien diplomate russe de l'époque
soviétique monte sur scène à la salle
gaveau le fond il veut raconter ses
égéries des femmes russes qui sont bien
souvent resté dans l'ombre d'hommes
auxquels elles ont tant apporté
[Musique]
les égéries c'est un phénomène unique du
20e siècle
on a raté personne d'ali russe gala que
j'ai bien des personnes elsa aragon il y
avait évidemment in war avec avec gala
il y avait max est avec galatto si tu
vas y avait eu cette dame que je préfère
rentrer tout lydia inspiratrice discrète
cacher une grande histoire avec mathis
l'inspiratrice de matty j'aurais pu
continuer à l'infini léger comprenez que
nadia et ces femmes les égéries
il joue un rôle essentiel pour
comprendre pour nous faire comprendre
plutôt cette russie éternelle est
vraiment souligner une grande affinité
qui existe réellement entre l'europe et
la russie s'étaient symbolisée par les
grandes histoires d'amour qu'on a
raconté pendant ce jour pendant tout son
spectacle
vladimir fédorovski ponctue son discours
d'anecdotes sur ces femmes qu'il
connaissait parfois personnellement et
dont beaucoup ignorent à quel point
elles ont marqué leur époque
il va de boue et inauguré le siècle des
opératrices parce qu'il y avait cinq
femmes qui ont régné en russie mais elle
était une grande égérie
comme s'il tentait de réparer une
injustice de l'histoire qu'ils ont
toutes en commun ces femmes là c'est la
férocité du 6 était il faut comprendre
que le siècle xxème siècle en russie
c'est une férocité extraordinaire 27
millions tués par les nazis
26 millions les victimes de l'église ya
la guerre civile de toute cette période
rouge les souffrances invraisemblable
gala me disait combien de fois je rentre
chez moi je vais me suicider et le
lendemain je me réveille et je lutte et
je l'aide pour moi et pour porter mon
nom en menant la volonté nos désirs
vivre y survivre et la mort de diaghilev
on est venu pas pour prendre mais pour
donner ces femmes là comment vous dire
il soigne la tristesse d'un autre époque
[Musique]
l'écrivain n'est pas seul sur scène et
l'a choisi pour l'accompagner des
musiciens et pas n'importe lesquels dans
votre spectacle
à quelle est la place en fête de la
musique la place d'un spectacle c'est 50
50 degrés est et je raconte mes
histoires pour mon public avec mon
accent évidemment je les en flammes
et pour ces gens-là choisissent les
morceaux préférés de personnes à risque
ils ont fait vraiment l'étude l'étude et
ce qui est étonnant parce que
extérieurement c'est la musique très
populaire accessible à tous dans les
rites et ses les grandes virtuose de
cette musique et c'est un couple
d'ailleurs c'est un couple franco-russe
et qu'il serait franco russe
ça c'est nicolas kedroff s'étant taillé
la connais très bien très bien ses
angles en grand spécialiste
mon ami mon ami mickaël roux dit il à 17
heures un vide dans la balle à leicester
[Musique]
et alexandre et agnès nikolov que je
connais depuis plus de 40 ans qui est
chaque fois
et eux ils sont vraiment ils sont
passionnés de la musique tzigane la
particularité que extérieurement sait
vraiment comment vous dire vrac ccifa
tout en réalité c'est une enquête sur
chaque fois c'est chaque fois très
profond et tout paraît hélas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et vraiment beaucoup apprécié tant les
textes et toutes les histoires qu'on
était raconté qu'ils étaient
passionnantes et puis qui nous ont fait
découvrir des choses passionnantes temps
aussi la musique qui est quand même
aussi très belle de très bons musiciens
c'est la troisième année que je viens
voir fait de l'hostie je trouve qu'il a
il parle très très très bien de
l'histoire de la russie doit pris un
sérail ça c'est un gars savaient pas
qu'elles sont et c'est lui j'ai appris
plein de choses rapport merci
merci d'avoir suivi cette émission avec
nous on se retrouve très vite pour une
nouvelle d'escapades culturel de
lisbonne à vladivostok
[Musique]